alex has lived here for eight years but
his home is incredibly unsafe
it's just a nightmare like uh we we live
in this death trap the cladding wrapped
around this block of flats is similar to
that of what drastically caught fire at
grenfell tower just four years ago
he's now being made to pay over 70 000
pounds to have it replaced
the four years we've already gone
through we've got to wait and see
whether we're going to get the money or
not which could take another one week to
one year who knows and then when the
work does actually start it's another
two years on top of that so you know
you've got nearly a decade of anguish
that you're going to be going through
throughout this process
it was the tragic scenes of that london
tower block which led to a country-wide
review on cladded buildings now hundreds
of thousands of people not only face
hefty bills but the prospect of a
similar scenario
it also means people like alex who want
to sell and move out are finding it near
impossible
it's heartbreaking to come in and you
see
your neighbors some of them are key
workers teachers doctors um and nurses
and and they're trapped they're trapped
in this place it's horrible
to help foot the bill in his budget the
chancellor is expected to confirm a plan
to raise two billion pounds
the government isn't putting a penny
piece up for
non-cladding related defects which are
just as common and just as expensive if
not more so so
the
the 2 billion is is a bit of
disappointment it's nowhere near enough
and we need a comprehensive solution the
funds will be raised through a tax aimed
at residential property developers but a
lot more cash needs to come from
somewhere
is it right for the government to pay
for this or is it for those who built
the homes um and you know
created the problem in the first place
so i think
there is um an expectation that you know
those who created the problems should be
paying for the solutions
many homeowners tenants and even
first-time buyers will be waiting with
deep anticipation for the chancellor's
spending review on wednesday but even if
extra money is announced it will take
time before thousands of buildings are
deemed safe intimate rasheed sky news
london